welcome back to glamour and filtered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the queen of drama
Elizabeth Marvel man guys get danced at
cinema because it is pulsating me good
tense a but what I love about it is at
the center of this story the power of
this amazing resilient women I want to
know what have you learned about your
own strength as a woman one of the
things that I found really interesting
when I did sort of some research for
this role was that is sort of
discovering my own biases that I perhaps
had held against women and abusive
relationships er victims of domestic
violence or abuse we tend to sort of go
why why doesn't she get out of that
what's wrong with her why is she still
with that guy
my discovery that there what that really
is what that relationship really is and
what it really feels like to be that
victim was really eye-opening and I felt
like I sort of let go of some of my own
biases you know what do you feel like
you let go of in that experience there's
nothing to do with your strength or
intelligence as a woman if you're in
that situation has nothing to do with
that and I think we tend to go oh well
why they what is what a choice they're
making why are they making that choice
it's not a choice and it's not their
fault I think that discovery was very
eye-opening for me you know I think one
of the things that makes it so hard for
women or men in these situations is not
to think they can talk about it and
there isn't a safe place for them to go
where they're gonna be judged so I would
hope that that is something that after
you're entertained after you scream and
after you eat your popcorn and you've
flies everywhere um I hope that
afterwards you go you know what I'm
gonna have a chat with that person and
see if there's anything that they need
to talk about yeah you know I mean the
power of talking in your own life yeah I
mean I believe in communication I
believe it's sort of something that
really will fix most things if you just
kind of have a conversation about
something and listening I think
listening is important we so often or so
just like at the sound of our own voices
you know it's important to listen to
other people's viewpoints I think about
this all the time because we spend so
much time in our society today like
we're over
with information everyone's just waiting
for their opportunity to talk and
actually we're never actually listening
to each other it's true and I find if
I'm ever confused by a situation or I
don't understand something or to
understand someone the best thing to do
is just to get what just you tell me
what's going on you know and listen to
them and you'll learn something yeah
how's your relationship real South
changed I think the older you get the
more confident you just kind of become
in who you are
and also understanding what you need and
what what you need to be asking for if
that's what you need and you know that
you know I mean I'm a big Oprah fan and
I do think there's a lot that I've sort
of learned from a lot of what she's
talked about but one of the things is
kind of that idea of believing your
instincts trusting your gut you know and
and believing what what someone's
telling you about them and I think
that's all stuff that you just kind of
learned there's always plenty to learn
there's always more and there's always
sort of a place to grow to I think when
this became like an Oprah and I'm really
into it super soul Sunday here oh my god
I was just wondering because you were
saying about learning to trust your
instincts and believing in your
instincts yeah is there a time that
you've leaned in to your gut and it's
paid off for you yeah I would I would
say there's so a lot a lot and in
whether it's personal relationships or
or work even you know when you have a
feeling and you're watching something as
a producer you're watching something and
you're going it doesn't work or you're
reading a script and yours doesn't work
it doesn't make sense to me
and and trusting that trusting that
instinct allowing yourself to be like
okay what the fact that maybe it's not
working yet yeah you know I think it's
something I do every day that's such a
great thing you can say here and say
that you have that belief in that guy I
mean you have to remind yourself it's
not like perfect at it you do have to
kind of go remember the thing about the
thing you're supposed to do because you
have gone through your career and
achieved so much I mean that mantelpiece
must be like chock-a-block by now
cluttered
it's just cluttered it doesn't look good
it's just letter there's like books and
sure
and it's just like and then it's like
just a mess just the all golden glaze
odd gold you can see yourself down the
you at the beginning of your career
given everything you've learned from
these amazing roles you've played what
advice would you want to give the you if
you could sit her here right now what
would you want to say to her um I
suppose I would say the thing that I
think a lot of us would say to their
younger selves which is gonna be okay
don't worry about it it's gonna be
alright I think when we were younger and
you're coming up you're sort of you
worry about this thing and that thing
and did I get that job and why didn't I
say that and you know oh I look this way
or that way and I think eventually you
go well things these things work out for
a reason and follow your you know your
instincts again and in your heart and it
will eventually lead you the right way
so I think I would tell myself give you
alright cuz he was just mentioning the
idea about is relationship yourself and
looks and all that kind of stuff how has
that changed for you as well this
relationship because we talked a lot
about your inner self what about your
outer self how is that I mean that just
goes hand in hand I think the more
confident you are about your inner self
and the more you know yourself the more
confident you are about your outer self
you know I become somebody who you know
wants to wants to look good and wants to
feel good but it's never been the thing
that has been most important to me
that's the thing I've always played
characters that aren't necessarily
looking their best
I really lean into some of it good stuff
yeah I'm the one who's like can we look
worse like if I come into work and I
have clear eyes like blue eyes cuz I've
somehow magically got in tonight's it's
like I'm it's a disaster mmm the makeup
artist is like well I don't know what to
do with this you know like I can see
your eyeballs and that shouldn't that's
not good
so for me I I've used that a lot so I've
never prioritized that in in my career
and I suppose not in my personal life
either very much that's kind of amazing
your career has given you that gift
almost no really is there's not many
people get that and go like I know I
know it's really nice it's a nice to
have to like go into work and not worry
about the bags they actually work for
you you know this is great because I was
like how bad are the bags today oh that
mine gets so bad
thank God I have wonderful makeup artist
Daniel more care of it but sometimes
nothing there's nothing one can do
especially early in the morning so
there's a lot of I masks
we're just ice yes I'm like Joan
Crawford now in the morning with just
like just a bucket of ice on my face I
don't go you gotta put in the sink and
just dunk your head in doing that couple
of weeks ago this really broken
only thing that really gets it down it's
just it's like all that fancy stuff and
honestly you just need I guess we just
need God's giving highs is what we do
blessed babies be praise be I mean I use
that in my day say life all the time
fantastic I've like blessed be if so it
goes right as I'm like desperate thing
to happen I'm like oh my god that's
amazing do which is super sad it's
really sad I really am it's bad when you
said quoting yourself mmm so good again
Joan Crawford
you're really becoming a diva really AM
when I was watching this I was thinking
about so there's the toxic masculine
relationship in the center of it then
there's the big toxic masculine society
that she's in as well what does that
been like in your own life in these
whole like masculine pressures on
society I mean I've been lucky in the
sense of I've you know I've worked with
some really really great men yeah and
I've had I've had good experiences but
at the same time I am a 37 year old
woman so it's not like I've been living
under a rock I have had experiences with
that masculine energy yeah people keep
asking it what was the research you did
and I was like I lived for 37 years as a
woman yeah uh so I've been working on
this for a while it's interesting
actually talking to people men and women
about relationships and gaslighting and
you see this expression go across
people's faces and this sort of cloud
over their eyes because I think that is
something that in varying degrees we've
all experienced a version of that
whether it's it at work or in a toxic
friendship or in a relationship
all kind of had that moment where
someone didn't believe us or we weren't
able to be our full selves you know
because as well I think you're such an
amazing empowering role model for women
and men genderless but you with your
work you really do bring the plight of
women to the fore which is so incredible
and it actually makes us reflect on the
way that we treat women in society the
way women act in society for you as a
woman in 2020 what do you think is the
most pressing issue for you for me what
strikes me to my core is is autonomy
over your body and and and really it's
something that is very very important to
me and you know the idea that anyone
would decide what a woman does with
their body other than the woman herself
it's just preposterous to me so that's
something I think that's very very
important
because there's not enough respect in
society for women making their own
choices in saying a choice about how you
want to live your life and choice about
who you want to love and choice about
it's it's you know what we're supposed
to stand for mm-hmm especially as a
country of America you know it's when
you think about the idea of choice and
having the right of very lives and then
you deal with this like everyday sexism
because I'll be certain situations like
well that is actually a very sexist
thing to say how do you shut that down
when you come across it but do you find
you're more aware of it now than you
were that's what I find I'm more aware
of it I I think even even I have opened
my eyes to like oh that's not you can't
say that I find me and my girlfriends we
are much more aware of that than we used
to be which i think is fantastic really
really important even in everyday life
you go how that man's talking to me in a
certain way that's actually not right
and that's I think very important for
everyone to kind of keep doing keep
doing you doing would that be something
that's like a trigger phase that you
take quite regularly and you'd be like
well I don't like to be talked down to
and I think sometimes men even if they
don't realize it do it you know they
don't even realize it that they there's
sort of this little
treating someone like a little girl
thing that men can do and I don't think
they're even aware of it sometimes you
love a intense role you do you do you
like to deep dive right on air do you
you do yeah because always thinking when
I was watching this how on earth do you
actually look after your own mental
well-being in this situation I don't
know I don't really consider it I need
is taxing sometimes but I don't really
consider it something that is work I
love what I do I don't feel like oh my
god that really happened and now I need
to go escape from it like I know that
it's not real
hmm and so I don't get into my head
about it yeah is it kind of far up you
chicken away as well yeah it definitely
is for sure I've watched scenes of watch
scenes that I've done and been like mmm
I remember that day or like I know what
that scenes about like I it you
definitely as a way to exercise your
emotions in acting when I'm doing a role
I I have the capability of being
vulnerable a lot of the time and being
open and being quote-unquote weaker or
whatever it is and and so I can explore
that in a safe space you know thank you
so much